[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances frost i'm konstantine Kissin and
this is the show for you if you're bored
with people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about the
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is a blue
labor trade unionist and a columnist for
and heard Paul Embry welcome to
trigonometry good speaker it's good to
have you here the first question we
always ask is just tell our guests and
our viewers our viewers rather and our
listeners a little bit about who you are
what's been your journey through life
how are you here
okay well I'm a firefighter by trade
I've been a firefighter since since I
was 22 years of age I sit on the
National Executive of the the fiber
gauging union the FPU I should probably
make clear that some of the views I
might express now may not accord with
some of the views of the FPU trade
unionist all of my adult life I became a
trade unionist at 16 years of age when I
was stacking shelves in ASDA
I'm the National organizers of trade
unionist against the EU and as you
mentioned I'm a columnist for the
unheard website as well so professional
troublemaker that's a problem that's
probably always good to have you here
one of the things we really wanted to
talk to you about is the left-wing
position for brexit because Francis and
I both were to remain because we're good
people I'm off that is the running joke
on the show but we've always we've
always been keen to speak to people what
we try and do in the show is actually
speak to people who have different views
as much as we can as opposed to just
talking to people have the same view as
us so you're a left-wing brexit ear hold
on let me just get my milkshake
what is the left-wing position for
brexit because the reason I ask this is
we've had a bunch of people on the show
who are pro brexit and the main
criticism that we get always is why do
you keep getting the right wing is on
bread
is all about right-wing it's all people
who hate immigrants it's all people who
you know want to destroy beautiful
diversity and progressive tolerance in
this country so you are a trade unionist
you come from the left you you know you
are undeniably left-wing so make the
left-wing case for breaks up for us okay
well until fairly recently the the
position of opposition to the European
Union was always a mainstream position
on the Left it's only over more recent
years that much of the left has turned
into a bit of a fanatical Club in favor
of the EU so if you go back a little way
you can look at people like Tony Benn
and Bob crow the general secretary late
Bob crow general secretary of the RMT
and Jeremy Corbyn to shore and Barbara
castle and and real big hitters like
that in the in the labor movement who
were opposed to the European Union and
predominantly because they saw it as
what it is an anti-democratic and
anti-socialist institution an
institution that embeds austerity embeds
deflationary economics and you know the
view of people on the left is that
actually as socialists we are in favor
of things like public ownership whereas
the EU is much more geared towards
privatization we're in favor of
investment even at times of recession
and when the economy's flatlining
whereas the you you particularly if you
look at what it did to Greece is much
more in favour of a kind of neoliberal
approach to these sorts of things and
from the point of view of socialists
you've got to be able to elect some
remove the people who govern you that's
a fundamental principle it should be a
fundamental principle for anybody on the
Left they're actually the people who are
making your laws and the people who have
a large say over your economy must be
accountable to the people and in many
cases they're not and always remember
the five questions that's only been used
to ask he said whenever he met anyone
famous you saw us five
what power have you got how did you get
it in whose interest to you exercise it
to whom are you accountable and how can
we get rid of you must have been a
popular guy of course in the end but
back in his heyday in the seventies and
it's that fifth question you know how
can we get rid of you which goes to the
heart I think of the debate about the
the debate about the European Union
you've got to have power over the people
who ultimately are making your laws and
in many cases directives and regulations
come from the EU which the which members
of parliament have no say on and we as
citizens of this country have to have to
abide by you can then get into the more
technical details and talk about things
like restrictions on state 8 so at the
moment for example there's a huge debate
around whether we should nationalize
British still in light of the problems
it's been experiencing over the last few
days and actually if you look at any
regulations we can't do that because
they have because it's so in favor of
market forces they have to have what
they call this level playing field so
stay aid from countries which give in
their view and unfair leg up to
particular companies is wrong and in
fact in 2016 here you find the Italian
and Belgian governments third for trying
to rescue failing steelmakers by bait in
the mouth you've got things like the
stability and growth pact which says
that Member States cannot run a budget
deficit of more than 3 percent of GDP
now anyone who sort of understands
economics in terms of the the right
approach to tackle in a flatlining
economy and a recession what Maynard
Keynes taught us in the nineteen
thirties is that actually you need to
maintain levels of investment during
that recession because if the government
cuts and slashes at a time when
everybody else is doing it no one's
going to create a recovery so it's the
government's job to sort of hold the
line and that stability and growth pact
makes it very very difficult to do that
so in effect they've ruled out Maynard
Keynes even Keynesian economics from
from the EU and then you can look at the
you know the mass unemployment that's
taken place across Europe you can look
at the renewed tensions that have
appeared between particular company
countries Germany and Greece are example
so all in all this idea
that the EU is some progressive
benevolent Democratic organization which
is in favor of workers and in favor of
the interests of ordinary people is a
total and utter nonsense and and the
left-wing case was always built around
some of the stuff that I just said but
but now unfortunately so many people on
the Left it seems were falling in love
with it firstly to questions why is that
one of them left falling in love with it
because you know I'm in the comedy
industry where everybody's left and woke
and all the rest of it and we're all
great people we all hold hands and all
the rest of it number one and number two
why is brexit perceived as being a
right-wing issue
all right wing you know movement my
assessment of why they fell in love with
it is I think if you look at the change
in the labor movements who towards EU
fanaticism which it really is bordering
on now and away from EU skepticism that
started to take place in about the late
eighties before that as I said and see a
90 new position was always very much a
mainstream position on the left but the
the left and particularly the trade
unions in the late 80s had been battered
by a Margaret Thatcher to be perfectly
blunt trade unions had been neutered as
a result of restrictive trade union
legislation we'd seen the defeat of the
miners the Tories were looking like they
could government for a very long time
and so because of that the the left were
looking for if you like any port in a
storm and all that the hill-road the
road the EU and at that time they had
sort of left-leaning bureaucrats alike
of reactor law it was only you I think
the President of the EU Commission and
in a very significant speech he
delivered to the so that he you see the
trade union Congress in the late
eighties he sold the idea to them of a
workers Europe and many people on the
Left thought right we need the use
protection as some sort of bulwark
against against Thatcherism and the
truth is it was just a load of sauce
because the EU has never been
particularly in favour of workers rights
if you look at most workers rights that
have come about in this country they've
kind of come about as a result of trade
union struggles through the UK
Parliament following trade union
struggles minimum wage trade union
recognition Health and Safety law equal
pay all of that stuff was would came
about as a result of struggles by trade
unions in this country the question
about wire breaks is perceived as a as a
right wing project I think largely
because of the things I touched on
because there are so few people on the
left now who articulate an NCE you
position is almost like with abandoned
the field to the right so it's not
surprising that if you see so many
people on the right who are arguing in
favor of brexit and so few people on the
left I think people will infer from that
but actually it must be it must be a
right-wing project but it really isn't I
mean under the under the surface there
are trade unionists and people on the
Left who will put their head above the
parapet sometimes and argue back but you
know one of the arguments that was made
to me is is that there's no such thing
as a left-wing exit from the EU because
the Tories are in charge and there's no
left-wing exit so we should remain to
which my argument well there's no such
thing as a left-wing remain either you
know if you look at if you look at the
EU and the way that it's it's
increasingly taking democratic powers
away from national governments it's
heading now for you know possibly for
fiscal union as well as monetary union
and if you look at the way that
neoliberal economics are becoming more
and more embedded within that the EU's
DNA if you like the very idea that by
staying in the EU you know we're going
to we're going to create socialism is a
nonsense now you know I I don't describe
myself as Alexis here I don't think
there is a left-wing exit clearly
there's not it's the Tories who are
negotiating it the Tories are going to
remain in charge at least for some time
after after we leave the European Union
but my view has always been that brexit
clears the path if you like for a
radical labour government to come along
at some point in the future hopefully
and to be free from the straightjacket
of EU regulations and directives and to
actually be radical in some of its
economic economic programs so my view is
that socialism beforebefore brexit is
impossible it has to be the other way
around
brexit itself isn't a panacea but it has
to be a step on the pathway what I find
interesting with this Jeremy Corbyn
thing Tim coming out where
according this the day after the
European elections and they will
probably go out a few weeks after in
which no doubt labour have stormed it
yeah I doubt that very much but this
narrative about breaks of being a
right-wing thing Jeremy Corbyn yesterday
tweeted and you criticize him for this
that the only way to stop the far-right
is to vote Labour and I think what he
was referring referring to his you know
the brexit party essentially they are
the far-right when in fact I would argue
many of us very many of the people who
voted for the brexit party yesterday are
precisely the kind of people that the
Labour Party used to represent it's
completely an utterly insane and in fact
dangerous to just dismiss anybody who
you don't agree with as being some sort
of fascist or being on the far-right and
my view is the way in which the terms
such as fascist and far riot and racist
have been frankly completely debauched
over recent years and devalued means
that people who actually not that long
ago whose views would be regarded as
pretty mainstream so for example wanting
to leave the European Union and now
being dismissed as you know people
supporting fascism and the far-right and
I finally genuinely disturbing that
actually you know we still people alive
in this country who fought against real
fascism and people who fought in the
Second World War against real fascism
what real fashion fascism is about is
the total dominance of the state and the
leadership over the people it's about
government dominating every area of
activity social and economic and you
know the the idea of the supreme leader
no dissent you know no pluralism no room
for alternative parties to speak out and
often tinged with the hardcore racism as
we saw with the with the Nazis and it
means white supremacism and it means
Holocaust denial and it means jackboots
and it means you know people
with those sort of ultra nationalist
sentiments the idea that people who are
voting for the praxic party or even the
leaders of the brexit party the
candidates of the brexit party i'm
Widdecombe Claire Fox Nigel Farage I
disagree with Nigel Farage on most
things disagree with and widow come on
most things the idea that these people
are fascists in that sense or on the far
right
he's completely bonkers and I just think
it devices our political debate and and
it's dangerous because you know we saw
just as an example we saw yesterday when
as you say the election the early
European elections were taking place
yesterday we saw an old guy 80 years of
age or something sitting outside a
polling station in Hampshire wearing the
brexit Party rosette and it turns out
that this guy had served in the armed
forces for 22 years and he was attacked
by someone throwing a milkshake or a
yogurt covering him with it and
allegedly according to reports screaming
fascist and then cycling off but and
this is this is what that sort of
hysterical language leads to
unfortunately the the minute you allow a
narrative to develop where anything that
is you know mildly right-wing
center-right right off center whatever
is dismissed as being at the extreme end
then you're given an encouragement to
people to say look that guy sitting with
the rosette he supports fascism why
because Jeremy Corbyn tweeted that we've
got a vote against the far-right today
because other prominent figures on the
Left are saying we have to defeat
fascism because David Lammy
he's calling Tory MPs Nazis because they
support a No Deal brexit that's the
arena we're getting into and it's
sinister and people need to stand up
against this sort of language because I
it's factually incorrect and just
nonsense of itself and be it's dangerous
so the question I'm going to ask now is
this is that Faraj is widely seen to be
fascist or have links to fascism you
know or you know certainly hard right
parties is a truth
you know because this when I was talking
about it online people like how can you
defend Faraj how can you defend Brett
cities this is a man with links to the
far right
he's mobilizing a wave of hatred all the
rest of it I mean my assessment of
Farraj is that he is a hard-line
Thatcher right that's my view of him as
I suspect that he was perfectly
comfortable inside the Conservative
Party when Thatcher was in charge in
fact I think he was a Conservative Party
men probably around that time and he is
an old-fashioned Thatcher a libertarian
who believes private enterprise should
pretty much run everything believes that
there should be low taxes for the rich
doesn't want trade unions to get above
their station believes him rolling back
the frontiers of the state believes in
small government letting the free market
rip all of that kind of stuff I oppose
him on all of that stuff everything I've
spoken about and written shows that I
oppose him on on all of that stuff and
in fact just on that point you know you
you look easy as I said he's a
libertarian really that sees political
philosophy which is which is about small
government government not intervening in
the economy getting out of the way and
letting people run their own lives
letting private enterprise dominate etc
in many respects that's actually the
opposites of fascism that small state
libertarianism I don't agree with it I
don't like it but don't tell me it's
fascism because fascism is about the
total domination of the state over every
area of our lives
so no I don't I refuse to say that
Farraj is a fascist I refuse to say that
he's a racist you know if you look at
some of the the stuff that's been going
on with you kid recently Farraj so he's
credit it has to be said left you Kipp
when it started going in a direction
where it started straying into support
in Tommy Robinson and got Tommy Robinson
on board as a as an advisor now I've got
no time for Tommy Robertson at all I
think is a racist rabble rouser really
why do you say that well because I think
his record shows that he is and and I'm
someone who has argued as you know that
actually you shouldn't fling the word
around casually if you
make that accusation against someone I
think you need to be able to stand it I
think if you look at Tommy Robinson
there's videos circulating him online
where he's particularly disparaging
about Asian taxi drivers and uses the
the word pack in relation to what he
assumes is a pakistani taxi driver you
don't use that sort of language as far
as i'm concerned if unless you harbor
feelings of racism i think he's pretty
sinister in terms of his backstory he's
been convicted of various stuff he's
changed his name for whatever reason i
think he genuinely does have julius
links so I've no time for Tommy Robinson
and as I said Nigel Farage actually
walks away from UK because of its
developing relationship with Robinson so
so you know yes he's he's on he's
clearly a right-wing factor right Farraj
but I refuse to buy into the idea of
fascism the racism and what and where do
you stand on and I know but I feel it's
important to ask this question about the
whole milk shaker thing because I just
thought it was pathetic and puerile but
there is a large swath of the left who
go no that is a way to deal with these
people you you mop them you cover them
in liquid and then you and then you know
you make a fool of them before your
answer I just I just want to add I saw a
graph I think it was from one of the
polling groups and in the UK which
showed what percentage of which vote a
group approved of milkshake in an award
level and Lib Dem and Labour votes as 27
percent on those approved of it it was
six percent of conservative voters and I
think overall across the country was
like 18 percent so it's clearly a
liberal labour yeah thing it's
interesting isn't it because the very
same people who over the last year or
two have been lecturing us about the
need to tone down our language about the
need to engage in more constructive
political discourse to be fairer in the
way that we talk about our politicians
don't use words like traitor or betrayal
because if you do that you you know
you're raising the temperature and
leaving them exposed to vulnerable
attacks
they're people who condemned those on
the street who heckled and a soupery
outside Parliament the people who told
us to moderate our behavior in our
language after that the terrible murder
of Joe Cox seem in some cases to be the
same people now who are saying oh it's
only a milkshake get over it this is
political theater you know these are
politicians on the stump they've got
other expects a bit of criticism no I
think it's appalling actually I think it
shows that you've run out of arguments
if you if the only thing you can do it's
a challenge a politician who at this
moment arguably is probably the the most
popular politician in the country
whether we like that or not the only
thing you can do is to douse him in
milkshake then actually you've probably
already lost the argument and let's be
honest about it it's a way of shutting
down political debate because they know
that the minute they throw a milkshake
over somebody and they of course in
milkshake never killed anyone we know
that and probably is not going to injure
someone
but but what it does is it drives people
from the public square so you know with
the example of Farraj being being
milkshakes he was immediately I was
gonna say whisked away that's he was
escorted away he was a school in a way
and you know the opportunity to speak to
hundreds of people in Newcastle was
taken away from him because some idiot
decided to throw a milkshake on him and
that was it he was gone and actually my
view is if if you're if you're trying to
do that sort of stuff you're trying to
shut people up if you're trying to close
down public debate by physically
assaulting people at the same time as
attacking others for being fascist then
you probably need to look in the mirror
you know I'm all in favor of politicians
getting it in the neck in terms of
verbal debate I'm disturbed at the
snowflake tendency in our country which
thinks actually you know you can't be
offensive you can't push the boundaries
you can't be too
- cool - all people you mustn't upset
people politicians hold public office
they've got to get out there they should
do it more that you've got to get in
front of people they've got to listen to
people's concerns I'd like politicians
frankly some of the people in
Westminster to go to the Town Square in
places like Mansfield in stoke-on-trent
South and and listen to people and
listen to people berating them and so
I'm all in favor of politicians being
exposed to the public but you draw the
line at any sort of physical assault
because it's wrong breeding principle
and it shuts debate down and these
designs are sharp you bite down always a
strange strange world we live in where
the people who advocate the sort of
political violence which i think is what
it is are the ones that call themselves
progressive guys we wanted to take a
moment just to say thank you to every
single one of you who has supported us
on patreon who sent us money through
PayPal we genuinely could not do the
show without you having said that we've
now also found a corporate sponsor to
sell out - absolutely and it is the
magazine the week and the week is a news
filter that pulls together the best
articles from over 200 different sources
from publications such as The Telegraph
the FT or for a one liberal snowflake
fan The Guardian exactly and that's what
they do they do exactly what we do on
the show which is pull together
information from different sides of the
debate the left and the right so you
don't find yourself stuck in an echo
chamber and you can make your own mind
up and if you want to make the most of
this offer visit the week coat UK
forward slash offer and use our special
code which is trigger for your six three
issues of the week what the week does is
it allows you to read less and no more
which is going to appeal to people like
Frances you can barely read absolutely
and it's not just news as well it's also
sports or if you're interested in
football you want to find out the latest
details of the transfer window they will
have in that in there as well which one
appeal to Constantine because he's a
virgin but seriously guys we know that
you've got busy lives you're not going
to be reading 200 articles a day and
what the week does is combine all those
things in one easy package that you can
look at once a week and know what's
going on join thousands of trusts a week
as their essential curator news source
try it for yourself of your first six
issues completely free to take advantage
of this great offer visit the week code
at UK for
would slash offer enter our special code
which is of course trigger and you will
get your first six issues of the week
completely free what I recognize out of
what happened during the EU campaign and
the milkshake in all this is the people
who've been running around calling
everyone Nazis and fascists which I
always thought they were doing as a kind
of exaggeration they actually believed
that they actually believed that their
milk shaking baby Hitler that's what
they think
which is why they feel is justified I
think I think that's right i think i
think people because the the narrative
has been allowed to develop that
actually if you're on the right wing of
the tory party for example you're a
member of the ERG group or something
then by definition you're a Nazi and
fascist because this is what some people
in the media and some people in
Parliament are calling you then actually
people will start to believe it people
who maybe not actually be aware of the
real history of fascism and what it
really means I mean I I read a tweet a
little while ago where someone someone
said that they were living in Spain they
were a British British citizen but they
were living in Spain and there was a
people's vote march in London and
someone tweeted in all seriousness it
was a she she tweeted that she was
flying back to London to take part in
this March because it was important for
her to defeat fascism and that's what
this government in Britain was hold on a
second once upon a time people from
Britain went out to Spain to fight real
fascism and now they're coming back to
fight imaginary fascism that's that's
the level of hysteria that the debate
has reached and I just sort of try and
say to people on the Left look what you
need to understand is when you use this
language about people because when when
Jeremy Corbyn for example says vote
against the far-right today people take
from that that he's not just talking
about Nigel Farage he's talking about
the whole of the brexit party and anyone
who might vote for the brexit
so people who are inclined to vote for
the brexit party in many cases
traditional labour voters and in fact I
think a recent poll showed that 47% of
leave supporting labour voters not you
labour voters normally we're going to
vote for the for the brexit party so
when when you use language like that
about people do you really think you're
gonna win people back do you really
think that you're going to win hearts
and minds when you show no inclination
to understand what it is that has driven
people to stop voting labour for example
when to start voting for the brexit
party this is a party that is completely
without any sort of political program
and people are prepared to vote for it
in their millions on this particular
issue when you get a situation like you
had during these big breaks at party
rallies that have been taking taking
place over the last few weeks where Ann
Widdecombe can go to a working men's
club in Featherstone in West Yorkshire
which is about as as typical a Labour
Heartland as you could ever wish to to
find a former mining town and you know
get applauded to the rafters and
Widdecombe you know a right-wing Tory
when she's going to places like that and
being embraced then people on the Left
have got to understand that they've got
a serious problem I tweeted it's the
equivalent of Jeremy call been going so
the henley-on-thames branch of the
Women's Institute and via and being
cheered to the rafters it just wouldn't
happen and if it did happen it was
probably something seriously wrong with
the Conservative Party if that was
happening my fear is that there are
actually some people in the labour party
who don't want to want to win those
hearts and minds who frankly do believe
that large parts of what you might call
the traditional working class in this
country in those sort of post-industrial
areas are racist and reactionary and
nice of list and old-fashioned and
frankly we can do without them and I
think that attitude has probably been
emboldened by the 2017 election even
though labour didn't win it and it
picked up
swales of that kind of middle class
remain supporting constituency and one
place is that traditionally it would
never have one places like kensington
and places like cancer berry and what I
say to people in the labor I you know
I've been in the labor body for twenty
five years what I say to people in the
party look it's all very well it's great
to win places that you don't normally
win if you win in places like Kensington
and kinda pretty great but actually what
you need to remember is we lost places
like Mansfield to the Tories an old mine
in town
we lost places like northeast Derbyshire
and old mining constituency
stoke-on-trent south warsaw north
traditional labour heartlands which have
been labor since time immemorial who
after seven years as it was at the time
of tory austerity and cuts are actually
swinging to the Tories and away from
labour and you saw a real swing to the
Tories in some of those sort of
post-industrial heartlands
the the the the c2d eases their name
which is the occupation of working-class
folks it's arya majority of them voted
sorry the middle class sees flops awards
labour the working classes and flocks
awards the Tories 61% of labour
constituencies voted for brexit and if
you look at the 45 target seats in
England and Wales that Labour needs to
win in order to form the next government
35 of them voted for brexit as did 16 of
Labour's 20 most vulnerable seats so you
know my view is the Labour Party if it's
gonna be successful again if it's gonna
win power again needs very quickly to
reengage with those heartlands which it
has lost over recent years and by
demonizing these people as racists and
fascists then you've got no chance of
doing him but and just to make your
point I don't think the Labour Party are
interested and I talked to a lot of
people you know they'd sort of the
middle-class lip metric metropolitan
elite as they're known who were Labour
voters and they don't seem particularly
interested either and to me and it when
we had our Peter Hitchens on he made the
point that you know essentially this
Labour Party they don't represent them
so what you're leaving in those areas is
a power vacuum in my opinion where you
get someone locked the Tommy Robinsons
of the world have come in and go look
they're not listening to you and he's
right they're not I will I think I think
actually that's broadly truth I think if
you look at the
if you look at the membership now of the
light part see the data wrong the
membership was released about a year or
so ago and it showed that 77% of Labor
members fall into that occupational
middle class abc1 category many of them
are sort of university education
graduates many of them live in the South
of England many of them in in London and
the party and I think he's something
that predates call bin by the way uh you
know how Corbin's got his force but you
know I think is is right on a lot of
stuff I think he's absolutely right to
argue against the politics of austerity
in terms of you know cultural connection
the Labour Party is losing those
communities and I think you're right
there are some people in the party who
would be prepared to sacrifice them I
think if you you know you look at the
the Jillian Duffy thing was a big thing
for me
you know the 2010 election Gordon Brown
the Lemp Prime Minister was out on the
stump went to a traditional labour
Heartland Rochdale working-class
constituency was confronted by this this
woman Jillian Duffy had been a Labour
Party support for all of her life and
buttonholed the Prime Minister and just
expressed concern in in in not terribly
aggressive terms by any stretch of the
imagination just express concern about
what was happening in a community about
the impacts of rapid and large-scale
immigration and the pressure on services
etc and Gordon Brown obviously was
Mike's up and and privately said to
someone she was just a bigoted old woman
and in fact that that was what he did is
he said publicly what many people in the
upper echelons of the Labour Party feel
privately about those old working-class
communities I say that the Labour Party
treats the working-class now like some
embarrassing elderly relative it wants
their votes at election time but it
doesn't want to be seen in public with
them and you know he's in many respects
ashamed of them another example Emily
Thornberry MP for Islington South where
I mean III know Emily very vaguely and
and I like her in our respective that
she
the during I think 2014 the Rochester
and Street by-election where she was out
campaigning and she saw a sort of modest
home and there was a white van parked
outside and it wasn't Georgie's flag on
the on the hanging from the roof or
something and she she found this so
noteworthy that she felt the need to
tweet it with the caption image from
Rochester and again it just showed a
complete disconnect between the
priorities of ordinary working-class
people many of whom would should be
tribally labor because that's how their
parents voted that's how their
grandparents voted and this sort of as
you said this sort of metropolitan
liberal university educated elite who
just find those people a different breed
and can't relate to them at all and I
think there's a real debate beginning to
break out now in British politics not
before time between people including
people on the left like myself who are
arguing for a return if you like to a
more communitarian style of politics
which you know respects people's
affinity for place and for their sense
of belonging and for their concepts of
community and family against this was
what has become now the dominant
ideology amongst large parts of our
establishment not just on the Left
certainly on the Left but not just on
the left which is a much more sort of
liberal globalist open borders
cosmopolitan worldview and and I think
it's it's a it's a debate that's been
encapsulated very well by David
Goodheart who's one of my former guests
right ok well I think David as captured
the debate really well and he's talked
about how he was disowned by his North
London tribe himself because he came
from this sort of very liberal
background and he wrote some years ago
about the impacts of mass immigration in
working-class communities and how the
liberal establishment just didn't
understand that people's concern about
it wasn't driven by racism or hostility
to migrants but was just driven by the
disruption and the violation that you
know very large movements of people were
caused insert there their sort of sense
of place in their sense of belonging and
he's written about how we've got in a
book particularly called the roads are
somewhere how we've got a governing
class in this country which is part of
what he calls the anywhere breed which
comes from this very liberal globalist
cosmopolitan University educated
background who make up about 25% of the
population but actually exert much
greater influence well beyond their
numbers across the political debate
across political discourse across our
institutions at governing institutions
and the somewheres who make up about 50%
of the country the rest are in between
calls them Inbetweeners but some ways
who make up 50% of the country who are
on lower wages who are often in poorer
housing who have you know fewer skills
less opportunity in life who are much
more likely to be impacted by things
such as free movement in terms of the
impacts on their wages and local
services etc and it's these people who
increasingly feel disenfranchised and
disconnected from the from the political
system and those people are crying out
for a much more communitarian approach
to society and these are generally
people as I say who are are not opposed
to immigration and in fact you know my
view is that we are still in this
country despite what some people say we
are still one of the most tolerant
countries in the world most most people
are open to the idea of immigration and
rightly so they just want the thing to
be managed properly they don't want a
situation where you have open borders
where a government says you know we've
got free movement and invariably
newcomers will gravitate largely to you
know already hard press working-class
communities where the property might be
cheaper etc and just the governing class
says to people well it's great this is
cosmopolitanism this is multicultural
multiculturalism and will probably be
better off in terms of GDP so just
accept it just get on with it actually I
think it shows a profound
misunderstanding of the priorities
working-class people the idea that they
are prepared to see a fundamental change
and and rupture to their local community
as a result of globalization and open
borders simply because they might be a
tenor as a tenor a week better off it's
almost a Thatcherite argument saying the
economy comes before everything the
economy comes before your sense of
belonging before your sense of place and
what they've done through doing this is
they've toxified the entire argument
about immigration so you know whereas
most people I think happy to have
immigration just want the thing managed
properly and are tolerant and say that
once migrants are in the country they
should be treated equally they should be
given fair access to jobs they shouldn't
be exploited we should oppose any sort
of racism the debate has now gone to the
extreme where if you say you're opposed
to open borders people on the left here
oh you're an answer your auntie and your
answer migrant you know you're some
reactionary some nativist that's the
level and I deal with these people every
day I deal with in my union I deal with
them through social media they are not
open to a serious nuanced debate around
this issue because they see things dare
I say entirely in black and white and as
an immigrant just let me just add this
you know I completely agree with
everything that you said the the the one
thing I we were talking before we
started interview that's that really
pissed me off actually during the brexit
campaign was this country and the people
of this country being smeared as racist
xenophobes when I know for a fact in my
own experience and many people that I I
Know Who I am ignorance in this country
would tell you as I told you this is one
of the best places in the world to be an
immigrant but you're right I think that
there is a section of the left that has
gone so far off the deep end I mean you
look at an America someone like
Alexandria cause our quota is talking
about how he what if you don't want open
borders if that makes you race so having
an immigration system is racist and you
just got these people are insane I mean
and you must be tearing your hair out
because I mean I don't really see how
with that trend that you're talking
about happening with in labor I don't
see how labor is ever gonna win back the
the working class bar ever again
it's going to be it's going to be very
difficult frankly and I mean just on
your point about tolerance one thing
that struck me is is after just after
the EU referendum in 2016 the Sunday
Times I think it was ran a poll where
they asked people whether he you
nationals who were in the country before
the referendum should be allowed to stay
post referendum and what that poll
showed is that 77% of leave voters leave
voters said yes people who were here
before the referendum from the EU should
be allowed to stay and that's my
experience of speaking to leave voters
that they're motivated by a fundamental
sense of fair play and not by racism and
the picture that's been painted of them
as people who just want closed borders
and people who I mean Vince Cable said
the leave vote was driven by people with
a hankering for nostalgia and Empire and
they don't like non-white faces around
the place and they want to see blue
passports a complete caricature the
leave vote was driven by people who
wanted self-government and sovereignty
and a return to the spirit of community
and democracy and belonging and those
sorts of things and the interesting
thing actually is that since the
referendum those things have hardly been
discussed in a lot of the public debate
the things that actually drove the vote
including you know control over
immigration much of that has just been
dismissed and what we've had instead is
a very kind of dry technical debate
about the customs union and the single
market and the Irish border all of this
that's important of course it is but the
idea that people went into the polling
booth and said you know I'm against the
customs union fundamentally
misunderstands why people voted so many
in such large numbers in the way they
did and in fact in many ways in many
cases people voted for the first time in
their lives because I think people would
sense that in in general elections they
felt they couldn't get fundamental
change in general elections that
actually on some of the on some of the
key issues such as EU membership for
example the part is the mainstream PI's
were all over peace and
what's the point in voting in general
elections because they're all the same
we're going to get the same sort of
government whatever happens I think with
the EU referendum actually what they saw
was here was an opportunity to put a
missile through the political and
economic system to really disrupt the
status quo and to say to the
establishment look you forgot about us
and this is the punishment that you are
now going to get for forgetting about us
and in many respects you know I've
argued that in many ways it wasn't
necessarily just any anti-eu valet son
he was an NC you vote but it wasn't
driven just by opposition to the
European Union less still was it driven
by opposition to the continent of Europe
and people often conflate the two don't
they save you against the EU you're
against Europe actually the two
different things
and what it was in many respects was I
vote against the political establishment
in this country you know the people sort
of people saw all of these people lining
up the mainstream political parties
camera and Osborne arguing the banking
industry and you know the CBI and people
like that big business who they felt had
actually made their lives difficult over
recent years and we're in many respects
responsible for their predicament and
we're now desperate for their vote and
people thought actually no I'm not going
to vote the way that you want I'm gonna
do this because you've forgotten about
me and this is this is the lesson that
you're going to get and it was I've
likened it in some ways to to a general
stripe we haven't had one in this
country since 1926 not that some of us
haven't been trying to work we haven't
had a general strike since 1926 bit was
like a general strike in the sense that
people I think people knew that if they
voted leave it would create some
turbulence in the country certainly in
the in the short term and probably
accepted that it might hit them in the
pocket a bit again in the short term
there's a debate about whether brexit
will will be better economically in the
long term but I think people felt that
you know some of the disruptions to the
money markets whatever might make us
poorer in the short term but it was a
price they were prepared to pay because
they knew it was the only weapon that
they had and possibly might ever get in
their lifetime
to make their political masters set up
and say notice very similar to workers
going on strike and I say that as a
trade unionist you know you know if you
go on strike you're not gonna get paid
you're going to get hit in the pocket
you know it's going to disrupt
operations you know you're going to be
attacked for it but you sometimes feel
that actually that's a price worth
paying because in the long term it might
lead to a better working environment it
might lead to better conditions inside
the workplace and that's what people
felt they knew that it was going to
create disruption but equally they knew
they had to make their political masters
set up and take notice and the really
interesting thing is they still aren't
sitting up and taking notice you know
the the the the political establishment
in this country in large parts he's
doing everything it can to subvert the
vote and actually people voted leave
because they felt the political
establishment had stopped listening to
them and that political establishment
has spent the last three years proving
them right and trying to undermine the
the vote and my fear is that actually if
you do block brexit or if you have a
second referendum the forces it would
unleash in this country from people who
say right you know you've shut off any
democratic mechanism I've got for
expressing my view of or effecting
change you're now leaving me with no
other option but to take to take to the
streets and I always say to people look
democracy is like a pressure relief
pressure relief valve if you shut that
off the pressure doesn't go away it just
breaks out elsewhere and that's the
danger of subverting the vote the one
story that I always use about breaks it
as to why breaks it voters aren't racist
I remember in 2016 I got a cab from one
gig to another and the cab driver the
driver was a black cab driver who's it
was a black guy and we were talking
about it and he goes I'm gonna vote
leave and I was interesting why and he
went to me it's because they the
government don't want me here in London
and anyway I'm not saying that they
don't want me here because I'm black
it's because I'm an ordinary working
person they don't want me here they
don't want you here they want this to be
like Paris and that they have all the
Liberals all the very wealthy people in
the center and the rest of us can travel
in well it's it's really interesting
because if you look at the data from the
referendum I mean if you listen to the
media and salut
all commentators and some of the
mainstream politicians you would think
that every person from a minority ethnic
background voted remain and in fact the
data shows that about a third of B Emmy
voters voted leave and in some cases if
you drill down a bit more you see that
some of their motivation was opposition
to free movement and because they many
of them had come from the Commonwealth
in the 50s and 60s and felt that
actually EU free movement was unfair
because it gave a leg up to
predominantly white people who were
European whereas if you're a nurse from
India or something or the West Indies
you have to jump through more hoops so
there was this sense that there was a
profound unfairness about you free
movement amongst you know that section
of the BME community and if you look at
you know if you look at some of the data
if you look at some of the towns and
cities with higher BMI populations
places like Slough and Bradford and
Birmingham they all voted by majority
leave so so the idea that and again it's
totally patronizing to suggest that
black and minority I think people can
only vote remain because obviously you
know brexit voters are all racist and
they couldn't line up with them I mean
my own in-laws are Anglo Indian my
wife's Anglo Indian her family came from
Calcutta back in the 1960s and many of
them voted leaf because actually they
look at the country I am speaking to my
mother in more about this recently she
looks at the country she arrived in in
the 1960s and of course there was it was
lots of racism around much more so than
than today and actually they they
developed a fondness for the country and
they became settled in the country and
they established their home in the
country and in her case she didn't like
the way that the country is being
managed and didn't like any more than
other working-class people the way that
the country has been thrown to the four
winds around globalization and the way
that it's now dominated by people with
this sort of liberal globalist worldview
so she was very much in favor of voting
leave so so we do need to challenge this
myth that people from a minority ethnic
background wired by the
four must be remained votes as these
people it's an interesting thing on the
economy as well because I remember I
host things every year and economics and
Comedy Festival where they get comedians
to host discussions between economists
politicians etc and I remembered this
done to your point about everything
being about money everything being about
the economy
there was an economist there who kept
talking about the fact that the
communities that will be hardest hit by
the economic impact of leaving the EU
will be the precisely the ones that
voted for it
and I kept saying to him I hear we're
saying but they know that and they voted
to leave anyway people quite often
prepared to accept an economic hit if
they get something else that's more
important to them and he just kept
ignoring that question I kept putting to
him over and over and eventually just
threw his hands up and well well I'm an
economist so that's what I'm gonna talk
about it's a very sort of dry scientific
way of looking at what is in many
respects much more human debate around
what drives people to vote leave and yes
you know as I said earlier it's a it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of
working-class people you know the idea
that they are driven just by this
Thatcherite philosophy that is all about
the economy it's all about whether we
can make a fast buck out of something
just because people at the top might see
things that way it doesn't mean that
people at the bottom do and our despair
sometimes when I hear Labour MPs say
well nobody voted to be poorer well as I
said first of all there's a debate
around whether bricks it will make
people poorer or not I think it's an
opportunity actually to be a lot more
radical with the economy when we're free
from that from the EU and actually said
to wait the economy much more in favor
of working-class people badly aside from
that how do they know that people didn't
vote to be poorer as I said before
people going on strike every I've been
on strike three times in my career as a
firefighter
I knew that certainly in the short term
I was gonna be poorer every time I was I
was gonna you know not be paid it was
gonna be harder that month to pay the
mortgage but it was absolutely right in
my heart what I was doing because I was
I was fighting for better pay or I was
trying to defend my pension or I was
challenging the you know the government
trying to make cuts in the fire service
and all of those things outweighed you
know the show
term impacts on my pocket and for the
vast majority of firefighters who went
on strike on those occasions they had
exactly the same sentiment so our sakes
people just be careful about saying that
nobody voted to be poorer because if you
believe that then effectively what
you're doing he's just this missing
working class people as being motivated
entirely by money and and that was why
Thatcher approached the economy in the
way that she did because she thought
that was all that people were interested
in of course you know I think money
takes this thing out being poor as
someone once actually for many
working-class people that sense of place
that sense would belong in that sense of
community that the principle of
self-government the principle of
sovereignty the principle of being able
to control your own borders and being
able to resist you know the the
onslaught of globalization and
deindustrialization that actually means
a hell of a lots of people and it's
something that money can't buy Paul I'm
gonna have quite a difficult question
now in our politics for this we had dr.
Steve Davis on a brilliant interview if
you haven't seen it check it out from
the Institute of Economic Affairs and he
said that what breaks it is as a
catalyst for the death of two-party
politics do you think what we're
witnessing now with kolben and the way
they're abandoning their working-class
heartlands as a slow death of the Labour
Party and their sense there might be a
new movement or a new party like the SDP
coming forward representing the working
class I think it's possible but I think
we've we've been here before maybe not
in such a serious way but I think as a
nation we've been here before where it
looks like another party may break
through it looks like the death of two
party politics you could think for
example in the early 80s when the the
sort of old SDP broke away from the
Labour Party and there was a surge in
the polls and they did really well in
by-elections and then before too long
everything kind of went back to normal
but I do think there's probably more
chance of it now simply because I think
there is and I think this has probably
been a consequence of the referendum
that tribal loyalties as they were
breaking down more and more I think if
you look back to the nineteen eighties
you know working-class people by and
large voted labor because they knew that
the Labour Party represented them spoke
for them even if they didn't always
agree with it even if they didn't always
like its leader Labour Party speaks for
the working class the Tories speak for
the rich and the bosses and we have to
be labour you know my my dad was a
Labour my grandparents were labor that
was people's motivation it was very
tribal for people I think now that
tribalism is wearing away and because of
the referendum people felt able to vote
leave for example whilst knowing that
they weren't helping the enemy
the Tories because you know the Tories
who were lining up for remain and leave
they were labour people were lining up
for remain and leave probably less so
leave but they felt able to vote that
way without thinking I've betrayed my
class I've betrayed my parents you know
they've always voted labour and I think
increasingly with the the way that
Labour is becoming this this kind of
bourgeois Metropolitan liberal very sort
of youth obsessed London centric party
there are people in the country who are
looking at the Labour Party now and
thinking that party just does not want
me that party is ashamed of me
that party speaks for a different type
of person now and wants a different type
of person you know someone with any sort
of traditional views around you know if
you like small see conservative views
which many working-class people have got
you know this small see conservative
thread runs through working-class
communities in terms of their approach
to issues like the family and their
affinity for their country patriotism
their approach to things like crime and
immigration things that are completely
dismissed as reactionary and right-wing
but these people who have these
traditional views there was never any
inconsistency between holding those
views and being a proud Labour Party
supporter and the Labour Party once upon
a time wanted those people nowadays we
talked about Duffy we talked about
Rochester nowadays the Labour Party is
embarrassed by people like them and I
think the danger which comes back to
your question is that actually you do
leave those people open so the forces of
the right
you leave those people open so the the
forces of populism and I've got to say I
think it's something that isn't just
happening in Britain you can look at
look at the Rust Belt in America where
they voted for for Trump in such large
numbers you look at the July Jean
movement in France where people have got
together and said actually we want to
fight for greater democracy for economic
justice for national sovereignty they've
been completely ignored by the left in
Britain by the way the internationalist
left in Britain which will support every
international struggle by workers
elsewhere because it's the right kind of
struggle but the GLA John you know don't
quite tick the right box and you see
throughout Europe the rise of you know
what some people would dismiss of
nationalist movements but I think
actually if you just dismiss them as
populist nationalist movements you know
reminiscent of the 1930s you making a
grave mistake because in the 1930s that
kind of ultra nationalism was a very
expansive aggressive nationalism it was
about dominating other countries about
invading other countries nowadays the
nationalist movements in Europe are just
about defending their own space they're
not interested in going elsewhere they
just want to defend their community and
their culture and there's you know
democracy etc and that's why unless we
try and win the hearts and minds of
those people then they are going to be
subtly you know they're going to be
potentially drawn by forces forces of
the right and by other populist
movements and he's going to be very
difficult to win them back after that
[Music]
we've got about five minutes left Paul
and I wanted to ask you something
completely different to what we've been
talking about which is just to tell us
you've talked a lot about austerity and
obviously your former firefighter and
you work you still work in that area
what given what we've seen in this
country over the last eight to ten years
what is the the state of the fire
service in this country well this is
really an unwritten story it should be
getting much more coverage than it is to
the the fire service in this country is
being absolutely decimated it's being
decimated as a result of 10 years of
austerity and people are paying for it
with their lives
that's this I mean that's not scare
mongering we see in now a rise in some
places in the number of deaths from fire
we're seeing a rise across England in
terms of response times in terms of the
time it takes a fire engine to get to
the scene of the fire those response
times they're worse for 20 years and
we've seen huge cuts from the government
we've seen 12,000 fire fighters jobs go
over the last decade that's a you know
huge a number of frontline firefighters
taken out of action we've seen scores of
fire engines close up and down the
country and we've seen a cut of
government funding to the fire service
of about a third over the course of that
time and it's a really really serious
situation because you know the behavior
of fire doesn't change over time fire is
just as much a threat now to people as
it ever is in the argument that the
government used to defend uses to defend
the cuts well there's been fewer fires
over the last 10 years you know which
which there has but actually you can't
base a fire service around the
principles of supply and demand it has
to be done on the basis of risk the
supply and demand argument for example
would say well you shut the fire station
at Heathrow Airport because there hasn't
been a serious incident there for the
last you know god knows how many years
we don't use it just shut it well you
know one would do that because it's
about whether or not you've got the
resources in place to be able to deal
with the risk should something happen
and that should be the the approach to
fire cover generally across the country
so you know it's a real important issue
because people's lives are at stake
result of it and people need to hear
about it
and what's the morale like in the fire
service I mean it's really tough at the
moment because you know firefighters
feel that they're fighting constant
rearguard action that they're trying to
defend their service against cuts from
from the Tories they're trying to defend
their pensions Tories try to rip up
their their pensions and there's been a
you know struggle over many years to try
and defend that we haven't had a decent
pay rise in the fire service for the
best part of a decade even though the
fire service does a lot more work in
terms of the broad range of work than
it's ever done before and we do a lot of
work in the community now we're not just
about race into fires when they happen
we go out to people we do fire safety
work we teach them about the dangers of
fire etc we fix smoke alarms in in
people's houses to make to make sure
there is protected as possible but we've
seen really poor pay increases over the
last ten years and I know people have
left the service and gone off to pee
train drivers because the pay is better
in that industry and it's completely
unacceptable you know firefighters put
their lives on the line every day to
defend their communities and all they
ask is to be treated fairly to be fairly
paid and to make sure that they have the
right equipment and resources in place
to do their job and it's not happening
and that obviously impacts on morale in
a big way and as a former teacher I can
the teaching profession is the same
although we do tend to go on strike for
more than well we're out of time it's
been a great interview thank you so much
for coming on Paul let us ask you one
more question what is the one issue that
no one is talking about that we should
be talking about as a society I think a
big issue controversial but it needs to
be said we are called trigonometry
because I'm in the right place to say
and I think what I would describe as the
abolition of womanhood to be perfectly
honest I think we are seeing an attack
on
womanhood and women's rights through a
approach which seeks to abolish the
sexes in some way by saying that people
now can effectively just self-identify
as whatever sex they won and that
society has to accept that and the law
has to accept that and that if you don't
accept that then you're some sort of
bigger and some sort of reactionary and
I find it extremely sinister I have to
say and and I am very much in favor of
people living the lives that they want
you know if they're not hurting other
people I'm perfectly happy for people to
identify as they want to dress as they
want to worship who they want to eat
what they want but when the government
intervenes and says that someone for
example who is a man has the anatomy of
a man can wake up one morning and
identify as a woman and potentially have
access to women's safe spaces because
the law interprets that person as a
woman and in anyone who doesn't accept
that interpretation could be could be
arrested and prosecuted I find it pretty
Orwellian to be honest and it's almost
like we're now saying there there isn't
a definition of women and I say to
people who challenge me on this define
woman for me and against all sorts of
models because they can't because they
know if they did they would have to
accept that actually you know the sexes
are different and I know many decent
women who have been on the right side of
equality struggles throughout their
entire lives who are really seriously
concerned at this and have said well
hold on a second we didn't fight for
years to you know get advances in terms
of women's privacy and dignity and
security and public spaces and
workplaces etc only for you to
effectively come along now and say well
there's no difference between the
genders and you're in talk to use each
other's facilities and you have to treat
this person as a woman even though he's
got the anatomy of a man I find it
disturbing I find it sinister I find
people try to close down the debate on
it just by shout in accusations at you
when you try it
and it's not for those reasons in many
respects it's not being spoken about as
much as it ought to be and he said the
plate that needs to be had well it's a
good point I'm let's dig into for a
couple of minutes for answers because I
don't want to just leave her hanging
we've had a few people on the show and
talked to them about it and we've also
had a transgender woman on show how to
India Willoughby on the show to talk
about this so let's dig into because I
hear that argument a lot and I have to
say instinctively I agree with it but
the argument about women's rights being
taken away by having this the the one
safe space that people often talk about
is bathrooms right and there are two
issues I would I would kind of pick up
the number one the easiest solution is
just to have cubic cubicles for
everybody then it's not an issue another
thing is if you are a sex offender I'm a
male sex offender who wanted to get into
a woman's bathroom you can do that
without self identifying as a woman now
anyway right so I don't really give you
a give us a bit more on where you think
this is something that has an impact on
women's rights well I think in terms of
the example you use if someone tried to
do it now they could walk through the
women's into a women's I've done it a
couple of times by completely you could
go into the women's bathroom but
actually you know you you could be
challenged and you could say someone
could say actually you've got no place
in here you should go I think if you if
you say effectively there's no
difference between the sexes and people
should be entitled sir and there's a
debate about whether people would be
entitled to trans people would be
entitled if they self-identify to use
the spices of of the other sex and the
fear is that if they do then actually
you can't challenge them because if you
do you're discriminating against that
person and even if the government does
say well we are going to preserve you
know safe spaces there will be
exemptions in terms of bathrooms etc
what we see in is a creeping acceptance
among institutions firms etc that
because they don't want to be accused
of discrimination and they just let it
happen anyway even if they did have the
right under law to say well no this is
an exempt safe space it was a story
recently Topshop in London where I think
somebody tried to access either that
women's fitting rooms or the women's
toilet or something and Topshop would
have been within its rights under law to
say no but just completely capitulated
when there was this Twitter storm saying
that you are discriminating against
people and I I just I just think is and
I think sometimes you have to think
personally I mean I've got a young
daughter would I want my young daughter
to be in a changing facility with
somebody who had the anatomy of a man
but identified as a woman no absolutely
not under any circumstances and I would
challenge anybody who said that I should
have to accept that I mean I totally
accept that people who having you know a
personal crisis around their their
gender and their identity need
compassion and people should be
sympathetic towards those people and
understanding towards those people but
it shouldn't extend to effectively
saying that there isn't such a thing now
as sex as biological sex you know it's
it's kind of disappeared and we are who
we want to be in society just has to
pick that up and run with that I think
that has really disturbing implications
and on that non controversial we saw in
the interview if people want to find you
online Paul what is where is the best
place to find you what's your Twitter my
Twitter is Paul Embry
in my name Paul Embry pretty active on
Twitter and I write a column for the
unheard website from science times I go
on the unheard website you can see some
of my stuff there and and disagree with
it and or agree with it you might and so
those are probably the two best places
to go yeah Paul he's very active on
Twitter I follow him with great interest
as always follow us I just wanted to
give a shout out to a couple of people
who have had a couple of PayPal
donations from people who I will not
name because we don't want the names to
be tarnished in public by association
with us but thank you very much guys
you're really making us given us an
opportunity to keep the show going and
by
so soon yeah yeah of course soup and soy
that's you yeah hang ten comment now
yeah I'm sorry boy carry on what do you
have in your in your tea what do I have
in mine it's not what it's not the point
my that isn't time we go to a [ __ ]
restaurant you know what Francis does
have you got any non milk alternate non
though have you got any non dairy
alternatives mate there's nothing wrong
now I'm just so shaming you yeah anyway
follow us on all the social media add
trigger pod click the bell button next
to subscribe button if you haven't
already subscribed and we'll be back
next week with another episode well with
shame for answers for something else
absolutely leave us a review on iTunes
tell everybody that you can about it all
the rest of it Constantine you're a
doughnut what have you forgotten to
promote oh yes I am doing my Edinburgh
show in August it's called all well that
ends well you can buy tickets there's a
trailer on my Twitter profile Francis
will be doing a couple of shows here the
Bill Murray in London here in London at
the Bill Murray as well check that out
in late August yep to come and see me
then yeah and thank you guys for
watching the shows right anything else
you wanted to say no one's listening by
this no everybody three people thank you
for listening and we will see you next
week bye bye
[Music]
there's the fall that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
the UNICEF on campus at SOAs right it
was asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti-religion anti atheism
I think you're doing some quite
complicated mental arithmetic to offset
the fact people didn't think you were
funny
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you're just I mean you're
just so paying a Bevan all right you
know all right that we got there in the
end you did a good thing by people
thematic needed right as I know I've got
an itch problem is I haven't got any
racist sexist homophobic jokes never
been a student at the University where
you can't make any joke about anything
if these poor little hokey students get
upset or drinking get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't know I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become anyone Gareth Bale right
when from talking them to round the tree
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money everybody feels like we're
we're all kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and can they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why this story's got the
resonance though it has
[Music]